The Tour de France is an annual multiple stage bicycle race primarily held in France...
...with occasional passes through nearby countries.
Held over three weeks spent in July, it's a grueling test of human endurance...
...covering approximately 3500 kilometers stretched over 21 stages...
...of multiple styles of terrain.
To put that into perspective that's roughly the distance from London to Tel Aviv,...
...New York to Las Vegas, or Melbourne in Australia to Perth.
The modern editions of the Tour de France consists of 21-day long segments or stages...
...held over a 23-day period.
While the route of the modern Tour de France changes each year,...
...the format of the race stays the same.
With the eventual winner being the cyclist with the lowest cumulative time...
...across three different types of stage categories.
This includes, Time Trials where the cyclist competes individually against the clock...
...using an aerodynamic bike and gear;...
...Flat Stages, usually a high-speed section across the French countryside;...
...and Mountain Stages which take you to the Pyrenees and the Alps....
...and make it the hardest part of the tour.
All of the stages are timed to the finish...
...with the riders' finishing times compounded with their previous stage times.
The rider with the lowest aggregate time is the leader of the race...
...and gets to wear the coveted yellow jersey.